all right for those joining this
livestream this is one of a series of
meetings discussing quantum computing
capabilities M of language or simulation
of quantum computing capabilities in or
from language and let's get going okay
so where were we last time so we've got
did we already go over we already went
over a whole bunch of these ones right
is that true yep we we already talked
about the operations themselves and how
we split them up into quantum matrix
operations and quantum measurements but
something that we were discussing last
time which I implemented a version of
for now is a control flow in the quantum
circuit which allows you to do like
basically to condition on the results in
classical registers so if you perform a
quantum measurement you get a result
back in in a classical register and you
can actually choose what to do in the
rest of your circuit based on the result
in that classical register and try to
understand okay hold on and it's that
what this is representing here yeah so
the the three one two is representing
like the order of action of that gate
each of the like the numbers are the
order goes to the operation then if you
see there's that three goes to if and
there's a statements there and okay so
that was that's the the way right now
and I talked to Jose and we are not sure
whether this is the best way to do it or
using a hold form if and things like
that
one particular instantiation that does
work at the moment
it seems kind of wild to me but but let
me just understand what all of this
means and by the way whatever happened
to getting graphic design to deal with
these things so I emailed a graphic
designer and sent them pictures
the things that we had the things we
want but I have not heard back yes I've
created ticket and they I mean it's just
waiting for assigning designer for that
I think they are starting this okay
is it worth getting Jeremy to join us
here so he knows what we're talking
about and we had him in some other
meeting okay so yeah I think they just
need to study it and and examples that
movie sent them okay okay so this
circuit here this is this circuit here
yep so this says TL what on earth is TL
so I totally was the plant there and
that's at awfully gate is represented by
you see that that first line is there's
two dots and one like a control like the
circle so that basically means that like
you it's a control control gate so you
control on the first and third qubits in
this case and the result fine
okay we're okay so that's applying a
tough League eight it
such fun when these people when one
knows from years ago eventually they
become mythical people with gates named
after them but anyway but moving right
along just I can have my my old fogey
entertainment from that um okay
okay and what's this here what puts this
operation here this is three two one FK
a freaking gate another friend of mine
who I saw just a few weeks ago okay um
okay and then two measurement that's
measuring in the X basis yeah okay I
don't understand this notation that the
X measurement arrow one what does that
mean so there's you see that there's a
two like this yeah that means it's
measuring right right and so the reason
that measurement has an extra thing
after that is because you need somewhere
to put the results in quantum computing
really you can't actually look at the
state itself and look at every single
component after you do stuff to it um
but you can look at measurement results
and so okay so what what but that one
has nothing to do with Cuba one right so
what that is is there's an implicit
classical register which and you're
seeing which components the classical
register you're gonna put the original
head and this here is referring to what
to the saying so that's saying on the
third qubit you do this whole thing
which is what he operates on a classical
classical register one right so it says
it says that if the result of register
one is less than or equal to one isn't
sorry is less than one then you perform
H which is a Hadamard otherwise you
perform a teen this is basically
wow this is so freaking weird I mean so
what's happening here
yeah we've got these two different kinds
of things we've got registered numbers
here and we've got qubit numbers here
right so basically you can think of them
as being classical and quantum registers
so in that sense there isn't the whole
register there's just a qubit whereas
this is a whole register correct so
those are the positions in the register
on which you're going to act but so wait
a minute
this this one here you imagine there's a
single classical register well so you
can have multiple classes lists you
could imagine a multi component
classical register and you're just
choosing which component of it to put in
because you could have a in operation
that conditions on the results of the
classical register you wrote my first
and second components right but unlike I
mean what you're throwing into that so
basically these are qubits
so you are throwing zeros and ones into
these classical registers is that true
yes in general if they're Q dips with
different dimension then you might be
throwing 0 through K minus 1 or
something into those classical registers
yeah exactly
okay so we haven't really talked about
the classical register case before have
we no we hadn't but I talked about this
with Jose a decent amount because we
were discussing if you wanted to
implement more sophisticated quantum
algorithms and in particular if you
wanted the ability to generalize to
quantum neural networks you need some
way of storing classical like the
results of your measurements and then
acting on those in a conditioned let's
let's take a much simpler case for a
second let's imagine that we blew away
all the quantum stuff here ok and what
would be our version of a classical
series of essentially boolean operations
that we will be doing here so imagine
imagine these gates and in fact this is
another question which I think we need
to be able to address I mean so these
gates ok if I want to just use a toughly
gate on a pure set of zeros and ones ok
so it has a perfectly reasonable
operation on those things you know if
I'm determined that I'm you know it is a
it's at some level it's just a you know
reversible logic you know if I've got
definite classical values am I correct
in saying that I have two definite
classical or let's say three definite
classical values I apply this gate I get
three other definite classical values
true but yes that's true and I think
what you're getting at here is related
to what was done last time I showed an
example of how this package now allows
you to take a boolean function and to
convert that into a reversible quantum
circuit I think what you're getting at
is basically if you want these quantum
operations to act on the quantum analog
of a classical system so you could
basically it was some functionality that
will allow you to convert a bunch of
classical zeros and ones into a quantum
state yeah but I mean even at the very
simplest level how would I represent so
if I've got a standard boolean function
it's obviously not a reversible boolean
function right but we talked about last
time how the there's a way to it's not
in here um it should be in the notebook
from last time
okay how did we do that remind me so if
you actually if you want to just like
put it like like a and B X or C or
something like that you like make a
boolean function that's a and B X or C
and then you can
to quantum circuit of and then in
parentheses sorry yeah in quotation
marks boolean function arrow and this
that thing and that should do it
you
was it an Scylla so Ansel is are the
there extra wire degrees of freedom that
are used by the circuit that are not
your input state is not the same doesn't
have the same number of quantum objects
as the number of wires in the circuit
and this is a lot of quantum algorithms
actually use n sylla's most one of
algorithms use n Cilla's they're like
places to store intermediate quantum
results so so it's a wire which at the
beginning I mean it's it's like one of
these wires in a picture it would
correspond to one of these wires going
going without any specific input being
given at the beginning is that right
that that's exactly what it is and it's
basically initialized to zero and you
can think about it as being like you
take like the product state of the
things that you input and all of these
you know zero quantum states that are
initialized and then you go through the
quantum circuit and I assume that this
works if I just say boolean function you
know something like this for inputs and
so on
so that doesn't work at that point yet
because you so I'm not what is the
boolean function format there it's a
it's a pure boolean so if I if I were to
do um it's a it's a function so if this
function takes I think I can give it
like that or it can take trues and
falses that
at the moment III don't handle this case
but it could easily be adapted to fine
alright just a small thing and while
you're at it you should do the cellular
automaton case as well okay which is the
same type of idea you can say cellular
automaton you know thirty and then you'd
say in that case you would say think
let's see then you get that maybe that's
not such an easy case the interesting
thing about the cellular automaton case
is that you can have a reversible one so
that when so that then this triple
reversibly maps to another triple here
or in general you can have some function
that you know reversibly maps
you know of the of the of the eight
possible the two to three possible
configurations here we can have
something which reversibly maps get what
I'm saying yep um and in general one
wants function that does that okay but
so what you're doing here what what I'm
asking for is something where if I look
at this TOEFL e thing I mean okay so
let's imagine that I've got something
like um you know if I take this
[Music]
and then I say something like graph of
that vertex labels are automatic okay
that wasn't very exciting that's a
non-reversible the mapping right mm-hmm
there should be a way of getting from
the stuffily thing something which
corresponds to the reversible mapping
that that represents even in the
classical case if I'm not mistaken that
is given inputs like one zero zero here
that gate should output something okay I
totally see what you're saying and I
think it can easily be adapted to deal
with that um okay okay butBut so how do
we get out from this right like like the
problem is we don't have a good way to
represent reversible classical logic
and how should we do that what's that so
that's what the yes as you mentioned
before in general not all like you know
classical logic functions are reversible
but this this quantum like like circuit
framework actually allows you to in in
this reversible setting represent all of
these non reversible classical logic
functions I'm just with projective
measurements at the end okay but but
there's a different thing that which
mean which we might want to do which is
something I hadn't really considered
here which is you know right now we
don't have a great framework okay let's
talk about classical reversible logic
okay independent of any of the quantum
stuff right and how we deal with that
because for example even a sorting
Network which is an example of a
classical reversible system right we
don't have a great way to deal with
those they're that they're a little bit
elaborate I mean if I go and I find for
instance um let's see I go to
demonstrations and I go find um sorting
Network
we have a better example of this but but
um okay here we go
so these sorting networks here
god this efficient way to do it the new
format for this is so much better okay
so this is you see what you see what's
happening here this is well here I'm
gonna do an example here
those represent gosh will immerse err
okay okay so that's the sorting Network
right classical reversible logic system
yes
you understand right so what are the
problems with this is that every input
has every gate in this case a
transposition has two inputs and two
outputs ring okay now we don't have a
great way to compose two input two
output gates and effectively what you're
defining so so this is what do I end up
doing here um no this is probably I
think we have a way using fold pair
lists am I right I'm not sure but but my
question is if we were going to
represent two input two output logic so
so for instance right now what you're
saying is what you're defining here okay
so um how's a you understanding what I'm
talking about here yes I think I do I
was thinking of a sequence of
permutations like yes that would be an
example right so what you're doing there
is you've got let's say a register of
length five and you're asking to do
permutations of I mean this is the
sorting Network is a sequence of
permutations applied to particular
elements that's what those this that
list there the optimal sort for 15
elements that is a sequence of of
transpositions
correct
although I am a bit confused here oh
those are ones that can be done
simultaneously right those are ones that
happen to be in parallel because they
affect different wires yeah that looks
like a bit like at the compositional
cycles in which each cycle is of length
- yes but so the question the issue that
we have here is I mean it's sort of
interesting it's sort of an interesting
case that we've got functions that okay
we've got a list and we've got functions
that take it's a little bit like block
map they take you know sub elements from
here essentially we've got a thing okay
let's let's consider a function I don't
even know what to call it but um let's
say hmm wow what is this this is a kind
of block composition I don't even know
that's not a very good name for it but
what does that mean that means at each
step you are defining a set of elements
and a function to apply to that set of
elements much like fold pair list right
so fold pair list has the feature that
it has to what it returns always has to
be a pair if I'm not mistaken that is
that function app always returns a pair
it takes a pair and returns a pair
doesn't it yes but here why do we eat
pairs this is more like a like a
function of n - n exactly exactly
it's an NRI it's a it's a so what this
really is is it's not really a
permutation it's really a block function
composition something like that where it
takes NR a things here and
this is specifying that you take the
element so this is applied to ultimately
to a register here or something this
could be a standard composition of what
Roger calls transformations which are
functions taking a list and return
another list like like geometric
transformations yes but but it has to
also say where on the register you want
the thing to apply making sense isn't
that determined by the position of the
elements in the list no because what
this is saying is just like these ones
over here these sorting networks that's
saying that take elements 13 and 15 in
the register and apply transposition to
them right that's because this is the
expressed in a cyclic way if we had all
these looked permutations multiplied
into a single list the function would be
a permutation itself sure of the whole
register right I think what is
convenient is to be able to say here I
mean if we're doing it of the whole
register we don't need a new function
here if we're doing it over the whole
register you're absolutely correct it's
purely a series of a composition of a
series of let's say permutations or
other reversible functions on the whole
register right okay but the difference
here and this is what what Jacob has in
the quantum case is he's got this
notation that in the quantum case means
apply this function which has three
inputs and three outputs to that block I
mean to that sequence is your I'm saying
I see I see independently of whether
that are actually ten it's just saying
take those elements and apply this
essential irreversible rule or I mean
not reversible it just has to be end to
end
right right so it's saying apply this
thing so what it really is is it's
saying we're gonna have a list of what
to apply you know what to apply it to so
it's saying do that one and potentially
I mean this is actually quite an
interesting function this looks a bit
like curry in the sense of having their
function and the permutation that
selects the elements yes that's
interesting thought
okay so curry this is some kind of weird
multi-car age right some sort of
composition of curry yeah except that it
has this feature that everyone is an
end-to-end function because otherwise
you don't otherwise it the thing will
fall apart right so if those are not
end-to-end
well what nerve happens basis so you
need to preserve that once you are
information that's what you mean yes I
mean in other words what I'm saying is
you stuff back into the list at the same
positions you've got things from since
the results of that function it's a
really different thing if you take
elements of the list and you
reconstitute the list I mean that's
what's different here this is unique to
reversible logic basically the
difference between what you're talking
about and the quantum case is that in
the quantum case not everything is
completely independent you have
entangled objects and so in that case
you can't just put the result like one
quantum result of one thing in another
you have like these are there like
intertwined in some way you can't
disentangle them yeah yeah I understand
but but but I could imagine running yeah
I understand that but but what I'm
saying is the it isn't really a limit
it's not really a classical limit it's
something different but I could imagine
take that toughly gate take that fredkin
gate and simply apply them to a
classical register right and this no
and this diagram would perfectly well
apply to a classical register you know
can I see
and it could output 0 0 1 or something
yeah I totally see what you're saying um
so then then what we're seeing is then
the difference is do we live in you know
in a in a you know just a bunch of
extras or in a hilbert space um you know
is there a particular input or is it a
complicated you know Hilbert space of
possible possibilities um so what I'm
trying to do is understand the
degenerated case which is ultimately
your case here which is the classical
case right that that case there will be
it in a little bit of funkiness because
it's it's it's connecting the quantum
case to the classical case but I'm
asking what's the pure classical case
and you're saying um
you know this particular thing
is a one wire and therefore necessarily
but in principle this could be a two
wire thing so long as it's if I'm not
mistaken this could perfectly well say 2
3 goes to blah blah blah
right and I just wish you could do that
right now you could you could put in
like you know one two three and then put
in instead of H and T you'd have to use
like you know TL and FK because those
are three input gates instead of one
okay fine
but those are the okay but but we've got
two pieces here that's the quantum
operation that's being done but I'm
saying also this classical operation
here
could also be operating on more than one
wire correct
and I have not coded that up yet okay
but I mean I think that that classical
operation also in the way that you're
using it here it's a little bit
different from what I'm talking about
here because really it's basically and
if you know and then
oh boy I mean that one is really an
element I mean this is really applying
itself so
I'm circuit we are imagining there is in
a quantum circuit we're imagining there
are two things there's the quantum wires
or something
quantum you know components plus there
is some kind of classical register
correct
um
you
so and and those operations are then oh
boy this is so weird
okay so measurements
quantum side to the classical side yep
and this thing here says let's check out
the classical side and secretly do a
little classical computation on the side
in order to switch the quantum side yep
actually do that in a in a in an actual
you know thing with you know with a
cryostats and so on how does one do I so
I'm actually not sure about that I've
never been any like applied stuff okay
fair enough I I'm always a believer when
I used to do particle physics I made a
point of actually going to visit the
experiments because you you just
discover but unfortunately these ones
I've um you know nobody's prepared to
open that cryostat it seems um in case
okay so let's come back okay I think
this is a mess okay I think I think we
need to think about this more carefully
but let's just agree that it's a mess
and if we can figure out a better way to
do it I'm all game okay well I think
what's gonna happen is that if it's can
turn into a just a regular pure function
here but I don't think that's the end of
the story I think we need to solve this
problem as well but let's just scope out
what else we're looking at here um
we're discussing whether use some sort
of inactive expression because this
looks a bit like a like what and
dissolve does for equations and things
in that I don't think it is that I think
it's a look I think these are operations
I think these things here in a in a in a
correct world those are basically pure
functions right I think this should also
be a pure function I think the only
anomaly here is that this thing so far
as I understand it doesn't if I apply
that to actual arguments it doesn't do
anything does it you have to use quantum
evaluate to do that because we so the
reason that we did that is because there
are also properties that you can extract
from quantum operations and and quantum
states and we wanted we didn't want to
mix the notation okay okay fair enough
but then so one meta up
raishin here the quantum matrix I mean
okay
one problem I'm having is
you know one thing I'm sorry this is a
thing which maybe Sushma could note when
we have boolean function we should make
this work
for all the named boolean functions
is my hero good yeah I mean it's a
simple thing but that's just an obvious
thing to do because what I can imagine
is that we want a thing called
reversible boolean function
okay so here's a question we have an
enumeration scheme for boolean functions
I'm pretty sure there's also an
enumeration scheme for the reversible
boolean functions but for example this
would be um a reversible boolean
function which has the feature that so
unfortunately gosh there's a very yucky
thing here okay let me show you
something lucky so let's take this is
boolean function seven with two inputs
okay that gives a so let's just do it
with true/false
okay that takes is there you know has
two arguments right but in this case
because what we're trying to return what
we would want this to do is to go from
one zero to let's say 0 1 right because
it needs to return a multi element
object am I making sense yeah we could
call good craft a parallel series of
boolean transformations and then that
imitates the geometric transformations
that take lists rather than product yeah
okay but I don't know whether that I
mean it doesn't do us much good in this
case here yeah um I mean this is really
a well you're saying this is essentially
a reversible named function the fact
that it's boolean see it's not obvious
to me so these boolean functions here if
I say for this boolean function here if
I say rule plots of that boolean
function I get that which is pretty
straightforward now for the reversible
case what I would be getting is two goes
to two I'm making sense to or doing to
number two two inputs there like one one
goes to let's say zero one here I see
now the problem is that it's not quite
as obvious how you do the enumeration
because in this case the enumeration is
simply taking those bits and turning
them into a number right right so it's
slightly trickier to do the enumeration
and maybe maybe there is no reasonable
enumeration and maybe instead the only
way to do it is with an explicit mapping
that says you know 1 0 goes to 0 1 you
know 1 1 goes to 0 0 whatever it is
right and that mapping has to be a
permutation of the states go what I'm
saying
exactly right and that's something that
hopefully does is a permutation of the
states right yeah a permutation of the
of the three three elements
whatever's okay so in general yeah right
so these what we're saying here yes so I
think what that was saying is that
instead of calling them boolean
functions if we call them boolean
transformations then we have we don't
have to follow the fact that they have
to be Barack no I understand that I'm
not sure they need to be brilliant
I'm not sure we need to say that
explicitly but I mean boolean
transformation whatever okay fine
the main thing I'm concerned about is
what is this function here that does
this right so the basic form of it is to
say these elements of this thing here
take these elements and apply this
function to those elements okay right
because that is the that is kind of the
analog of what's happening in the
quantum case now it's different from
okay in the case of net graph in neural
nets we're also able to take various
inputs I mean if we take a typical
what's an example of something with a
net Gogh I don't even know why does this
have a net graph um let's just see
anybody know probably nobody in this
meeting knows which of these have met
Goff's um okay so here
nothing then it should have a Gras does
it it's not just a no it's just a chain
oh okay you mean with the grass okay
okay
right um
I think one of these more recent ones
has a golf let's take a look
Apple to Orange translation does that
have a graph yeah that has graphs
okay but they're very trivial graphs
okay so what do I mean here so what I'm
saying is inside one of those graphs
it's taking that's unfortunately too
trivial a graph I think yeah that's too
trivial across but you get what I'm
saying in these in these cases right
what's gonna happen is I gotta find an
example with more more graph in it um
buh-buh-bah what enough has that gosh no
you ignorant that's um Wow here's one
with more morgoth's um the Yahoo open
NSFW model okay so let's look at that
graph better what the heck why is that
even I see the reason that's a graph is
because yes yes yes that sub-element
it's a very trivial graph if it was a
chain it would just have one input and
one output it has two inputs there right
Rick
question really is I mean and you know
we're going to end up with something
we're graphic clay by the way I mean
this type of setup that we see here is
not unlike I mean that would be a
perfectly reasonable quantum circuit
with a bunch of to-to-to gates like if
I'm not mistaken controlled not as an
example of such a two to two gate yeah
so in principle we could make a you know
we could take the sorting Network and we
could make it quantum I I hate to say
quantize it because the concept of
quantizing things was always a concept
Mill annoyed let me not go on a
digression here but it's it's like
always people in the early days of you
know in particle physics and so on
people are like can we quantize the
such-and-such which is not exactly a
procedure it means is there a reasonable
way to sort of inject quantumness into
this thing without having the thing
become create totally crazy and so in
this case I mean a question would be
actually what is the answer that you
know the answer to that in the case of a
sorting Network
what is the quantumness of us I mean how
do you take a sorting Network and like
make it want them is there a meaningful
way to do that I what how would it act
on superpositions and assistance with
entanglement and things like that how
would it be any different I don't think
it's any different I think what it does
is it sort stuff and my question is but
I think if it is entangled I think it
sorts the entangled thing and and every
every thing in in everything in the
superposition I think is sorted I think
you know what I I this is ringing a
strong bell I think I once understood
this um
but you got my point that you can
obviously make a circuit this is a
perfectly reversible transformation
right
by a perfectly nice you know you could
make a unitary matrix that represents
this thing question is what is it but
but I want to come back to okay so just
to scope this out so okay so we got this
I don't see what roughly what you're
doing here so this is now concatenated
circuit so Wow
so there has to say how to knit one
circuit together with another circuit
correct yeah and that's all done
implicitly as long as the circuits are
of the same cuted dimension it handles
everything not only cutit dimension we
also have to have the same number of
qubits not exactly because the the
numbers on which these things act are
are actually inside the circuits so if
one has more than another it'll just you
know certain operations will act on like
qubits further down in your whole entire
like quantum state okay but doesn't that
then involve various things that
implicitly have to have and solos
running around no no not really I mean
there's just a dimension of the quantum
state that acts on the system has to be
different I'm confused if we have one of
these that has three wires and another
that has five wires and I say do the
three wire thing first and then do the
five wire thing what does that mean so
if you specify if you just had this
three wire quantum circuit then you
would only need a quantum state that was
that it had three cubits or you know
three quarters if you had something that
had five like if you you know you can
have it into the two circuits now you
had a circuit to acted on five cubits so
you would need a quantum state that had
at least five cubits in it and you would
specify I get it but I think what that
the point I was making is that if you go
three first than five you are implicitly
if I've understood these ancilla
creatures which just sound incredibly
fauna like they you know that would mean
that there was there were two and
sellers here in the in that three wire
quantum circuit or am I wrong
I think that there's a slight difference
in the way that we're referring to I
don't know okay so I'm confused about
what these done citizen right so in
sylla's are if you have another wire
that is active in the computation like
the wire that's not just like like void
so if you just have a you know a five if
you have a state quantum state that has
three cubits on it and you have a or
even even differently if you have yeah
if you have a quantum state that has
three qubits in it and you have a
quantum circuit where certain operations
have you know two qubits certain
operations of three certain operations
have you know one whatever your your
quantum circuit can have five wires in
it it's just going to be that some wires
are not active during certain like I get
it but I think okay well it's only an
answer is only we only call something an
n sila when it directly interacts with
like there's an operation that acts on
one of the ancilla x' and one of your
qubits okay it's fine fine so the non
interacting wire is not considered one
of these exactly okay
oh there's no ambiguity in how you add
the circuits together concatenate them
well this is cool you've got the
measurement distribution working that's
cool we talked about that last time yeah
yeah we talked about that a while ago so
in this case you do need this separate
symbol quantum measurement distribution
but it transforms it into a data
distribution and then you can do all the
cool things on it that's quite nice so
that's then the result of a measurement
basically that true any measurement can
be represented any of the that the set
of possible measurement results can be
represented in this distribution is that
true yes that's true as long as you have
the measurement operator like and then
you have the state that it acts on
because the measurement itself depends
on the state that you're acting on but
then yes it describes the entire
you know realm of possible measurements
are you you'll really try to make a
quantum you're on that aren't you so I
was just talking about it for so long I
I just wanted to show that it's possible
to do something like simulate
non-linearity and a quantum circuit and
so this there's still a little for some
reason there's a slight bug in the
actual circuit like when it you create
the circuit here and try to evaluate it
but the it was working at one point
where you can basically using the
control flow that I have above and you
know conditioning on measurement results
with a while loop you can do things like
increase the amount of non-linearity in
the circuit as you go you know this so
this picture right above is from a paper
that was like about quantum neurons and
you can see as if you do the circuit a
bunch of times you go from Q of X to
you know Q to the you know n of X and
you start getting something that looks a
lot like a step function oh and that's
very you know that would be very useful
for quantum neural networks if you can
feedback the output which we don't even
have a way to feedback the output of and
we don't have a way to recirculate bits
in a quantum circuit at this time about
back propagation know I'm talking about
a nest an analog of nest for a quantum
circuit that is right now and maybe one
could do that explicitly but right now
other than drawing out you know this
thing and x or whatever we don't have a
way to say connect that wire back to the
start so right now I think that a while
loop does something like that if you
look at VM like the structure below in
the like the last section so there was
there isn't an error right now and
generating the circuit but if you look
at the way that the quantum circuit is
like are you s equals quantum circuit of
join so that basically says you have
this initial sub circuit and then while
your measurement results satisfies
something then you join the sub circuit
with you know basically
I mean that's such a wild thing in terms
of the levels of discourse that are
going on there because I mean this
concept that you can symbolically take a
circuit and join it to another circuit
is is it a completely different level I
mean in other words if we were talking
about ordinary electronics okay and we
say Oh an operation inside this piece of
electronics is to join a new copy of the
circuit it's like that's nuts
because the actual circuit consists of
pieces of copper wire and so on and
there's no what
but isn't that the case also for these
quantum circuits at this point that
these things are still I mean unless I'm
mistaken there isn't a known way to have
a sort of virtual quantum circuit so to
my knowledge that's correct and I think
that the actual hardware element of this
would be quite difficult but you know I
think and that's why I'm you know if we
were trying to generalize this to you to
have quantum evaluate work on a an
actual quantum computer back-end that
would not accept these type of
classically conditioned operations you'd
need to have a an explicit quantum
circuit input there but a lot of quantum
algorithms the majority of interesting
quantum algorithms have some type of
control flow in them where so I think
that those are mostly at this point like
you know developments done correctly
most of the things that people actually
build a pretty feed-forward type things
right right so this is a capability that
is there but it's not probably is not
likely to be implemented in the near
future on an actual quantum computer but
is useful for simulating quantum
computing where by simulating we mean
you might never be able to do it in our
universe but it's still amusing to look
at I think we will be able to do it at
some point well so that this this then
means that you know the homework has to
be basically there are about three
implementation methods for quantum
computers basically to try to understand
which of them are virtual izybelle
enough to be able to do anything that
isn't nodes how do we represent you know
even the very simple thing I mean okay
the idea that you have to explicitly
join a new circuit on to get the
operations done again is like you know
reminds me of analog computers right
it's it's that's that's what we don't
have to do in digital computers because
there's purely you know informational
stuff going on um
but okay let's just okay just zooming
out cuz we're running out of time here
and hopefully we can continue sometime
soon before we've all forgotten the
stuff again um I mean I think look my
take here okay I think this stuff with
the classical conditioning is really
messy right now and I think it's gonna
take a couple more pieces of grinding to
get that into a form that makes sense it
doesn't help that it's not implementable
on current quantum computers because
that means that we're kind of what we're
doing here is we're making a model of
something where there isn't you know
there's nothing we can be modeling so to
speak we're essentially making it I mean
it will be like us adding okay let me
give an analogy which is equally bizarre
okay let's say we decide to add to or
from language an Oracle for Turing
machines okay does this make any sense
we can just say let's have a nominal
function called halting queue that when
given a Turing machine specification
tells us whether it halts or not now in
our actual universe we can never
evaluate this function except in certain
cases where it so happens that we can
readily verify that the Turing machine
halts so that it doesn't hold but there
will certainly be be sort of edge cases
where that function is not evaluatable
so far as we know in our universe but
there's nothing wrong with us
symbolically you know giving that
function just like you know we have the
variable infinity that represents
infinity which we can you know juggle
around us as we please but we can't
actually instantiate in our universe so
I think that this is the same type of
thing that we're talking about things
where I mean whether there is an
implementation method allows it to be
instantiated that is in you know where
there's a conceivable implementation
method I don't don't know um it worries
me a little bit to be building something
where in other words okay the question
is were we to have a function whole
think you
could certainly you know figure out
properties of halting queue like you
know if there's hole think you and you
know does it obey the law of excluded
middle and things like this does it does
it you know it has various whole thank
you has plenty of symbolic properties
just like infinity as symbolic
properties and my claim would be
yeah I mean I guess the argument has to
be that this thing that we're talking
about here has in a sense symbolic
properties
that apply symbolic properties in the
sense that it can describe the
transformation to a hilbert space for
example in a way that
yeah I mean even if we can't implement
it in the physical universe at least now
yeah all right I'm kind of rambling to
myself but but there was this I mean
Hosea do you have any comments on all of
this not really at the other levels you
are discussing now okay no the only
thing that worries me is so many things
that are here so it's a yeah there are a
lot of different tentacles exactly yeah
yeah but I think we're trying to make a
full you know quantum computing
simulation framework that handles all
the cases people are interested in
simulating then we do need something
like this yeah I understand I get it I
mean I just the issue is I mean what
we're realizing is okay there are
different kinds of things like quantum
measurement distribution things like
this um and
it's an interesting question whether we
can simply say whether we can have some
wrapper around quantum measurement which
gives the quantum measurement
distribution that that's a detail okay
the you know the language design thing
one language design thing that I would
like to deal with is this question about
these what the heck should we call them
these end end functions what is an
end-to-end function it's not an N or a
function what would it be called it's
not necessarily reversible but it is a
function whose arattai whose output
arity equals its input NRT well given
that we are we don't want to return a
sequence the only possibility is a list
- a list I think yes and every time we
we have tried to enter multi-dimensional
calculus multivariate calculus it's the
it's what we did in coordinate chart
data or geometric transformation no I
understand you don't have a problem with
that I'm saying here this thing I mean
this is like
it's almost like a sparse function
composition is that completely crazy so
what I mean by that is when we have a
sparse array we're saying um a sparse
array says elements bla bla bla are
equal to bla bla bla this is saying
labeling those elements much like we do
in a sparse array apply yeah I see what
you're going this is some sort of
alternative to Association because
Association complains when it gets a key
that it doesn't have so here it will be
something like like if you get something
that you don't have written it actually
know what you know there's a I'm
confused here look look what we need is
a function is something which simply
takes okay this is a you are right that
this is very Korea stick I mean okay so
look it's something like this where the
only thing it takes is something like
two three one function okay and that
applies to a whole long list here and
what it returns is the result whatever
you know whatever you know one prime you
know to the result saying those right so
okay how does that relate to curry curry
it's not quite curry it's it's it's
specifying in a list it's a okay okay
let's try a different name what about
sequence apply if I say sequence apply F
comma two three one
or even this also looks a bit like every
place in the sense that it's replace the
list and then to say one goes 12 now
because you have to re re puff it out
again because the result F is itself a
list and that list has to be spliced
back into the original list right but
that's like replaced part will not touch
the things you didn't mention I
understand but replaced part doesn't
splice back in replaced part takes the
part and it doesn't go end to end so to
speak what this is doing is it goes to
end to end and then it splices the
resulting end things back into the list
yes so if we go to be a function it's
fine I was just thinking that this is
not apply no it is not apply it's also
not really it's some kind of gosh what
is it it's it's it's a little like this
I don't think that's quite the right
name but this is I think the right
functionality this is name here's the
function and here's the positions to
which it applies I mean it's it's almost
what's that hmm but map at again returns
a single thing what this is doing is its
returning in this case three things
which it then you know replaces in this
list at the correct positions okay right
the other case that comes to mind is
it's the cyclic notation for
permutations which also specifies the
places it has to act and then the rest
are left untouched so you could have
those cycles added plus 100 and then it
would it would do nothing on the first
hundred element and it would touch the
hundred 100 - what does it do
yeah what what does what does one do
with this there are examples where it
does something well this is first
explaining that what it does and then in
properties not relations I guess they
will be used for some operations like
permutations replace right so so you can
see that's a permutation that's
representing a permutation exactly and
then that's for example that when you
are pointing at its its its map in 3 to
2 but what I mean is that if that was
100 a hundred and 302 you could put a
list in the first argument with 200
tournaments and it would only touch the
hundred 100 200 3 so you're saying if I
do this then I put in that first element
I put range of 10 for example exactly
you see that is the first three but not
the rest okay that is highly relevant
yes um we have to go to a different I
have to go to different meetings nothing
actually um we need to continue this
this is an interesting language design
problem where should I save this I guess
I say this under quantum although this
is really a slightly different thing um
okay I gotta go to the soda meeting
hopefully we can continue this soon and
this particular language thing is it's
just it's own separate language design
problem see
okay all right great
thanks a lot guys thank you to people on
the live stream